What to do when you have a conflicting genetic defect that is
CONT defects with MTRR defects.
CONT genes help produce multiple things but they function in the myopterid pathway
and they help with the neurotransmitter function.
The MTR or the MTRR genes are in the vitamin B12 corbolamine pathway in the natiety and pathway.
For one, you should take hydroxyl corbolamine and the other methyl corbolamine, thanks.
Well, first of all, you don't treat genetic defects. You don't go, okay, you have
CONT defects, so you should be this or you should have a MTRR should have to be on this.
You have to look at it as a big picture of everything else that's going on with that patient.
So genetic, your genetic picture is just one piece of that puzzle.
I would be careful with methyl corbolamine with anybody because if you have a lot of other defects
in the myopterid pathway, you excess methyl groups are going to push that pathway and it's very
common that the person ends up with excess serotonin because they were diagnosed.
Some doctor did a genetic test on them. They had MTRR gene defects or they had
MTHFR defects, your methyl tetrahedron, folate gene. Then they were given a methyl folate or
methyl corbolamine thinking that, oh, well, you have an issue with decreased methylation.
So you need to be out of methyl-submethyl groups. They're given those methyl groups without really
looking at the patient's big picture. Where are there to transmitters at? Are there other defects
in the myopterid pathway that would suggest that excess methyl groups would be
not a good idea? I see that quite commonly. So that these people are given methyl groups because,
oh, my goodness, you have an MTHFR defects, so you need methyl groups. No, you don't. So that's not
the way to care for somebody is to treat them from a genetic standpoint alone. You have to look
at the big picture. Furthermore, a person has a perfect example. A person has a diagnosis of
cancer and you're giving them methyl groups. One of the things methyl groups do is they silence
genes. They turn off genes. And excess methyl groups could turn off tumor suppressor genes.
So if a person does have cancer, you are dependent upon your tumor suppressor genes to stimulate
intrinsic apoptotic pathway to kill cancer cells. And if you're taking excess methyl groups,
you're basically silencing that pathway. You could turn off that pathway. So I don't, if a person
has cancer, I don't want them on any methyl groups. Unless a bigger picture tells us to do so,
they have issues with home assisted or something like that. I don't want to put them on methyl groups
for a period of time. So again, you don't just treat one thing. You don't look at even one lab
and treat based upon that mud lab. You're going to look at the patient's big picture. What is
there other diagnoses? What are there other issues? What are there other labs? I don't just treat
you don't treat a genetic defect. You have to look at the big picture.